thank you so much Eddie for the
introduction and for the invitation to
give a talk in this wonderful workshop
I'm going to talk about learning what
works best when and so I'm basically
going to talk about two styles of to two
works one of them is more on the
theoretical side and one is more
computational and the first part of my
talk is going to be joint work with my
PhD thesis advisors Michelle Gomez and
Patrick Jaya and the second part of the
talk I'm going to talk about joint work
with Ian dining and Joel sipper holes
which we did while we were students at
MIT and currently Ian as a deep mine and
Shawn is an assistant professor at the
Ross School of Business so okay I'm
going to talk about three fundamental
questions in this talk one is how do you
compute projections so what do I mean by
that if I give you a point outside a
decision set or a polytope then what's
the point inside this body that makes
the most sense which is the closest the
distances here need not be just straight
line distances or Euclidean distances
but might come from minimizing convex
functions which are more general than
minimizing squared Euclidean distance
the second question is going to be how
far can I move given a point in a
polytope and a direction how far can I
move along this direction while still
remaining feasible the polytopes you are
going to consider will have an
exponential number of hyperplanes which
makes this problem computationally more
challenging and the third question
that's going to be the second part of
the talk is going to be about can be not
which algorithm or heuristic works best
on an unseen instance of data okay so
without much delay let me go on to the
first question of how do you compute
projections now the problem of computing
projections is important because it
arises as a key step in many algorithms
across online learning game theory
machine learning stochastic and robust
optimization
and in the next few slides we're going
to focus on the problem setup of online
learning very briefly look at an example
problem and then look at this particular
algorithm of online murder descent and
see where projection arises is a sub
problem so all of these algorithms
around us are constantly looking at some
historic data they have some prior
knowledge and then they use that
knowledge to make some decision given
that decision they observe some feedback
from the environment or the users which
are these losses or gains in the dynamic
environment and they repeat this process
over time to improve their learning and
achieve some goal of maybe showing the
best recommendations to users or showing
parts with the least amount of
congestion to people who are travelling
in a road network and the metric of
performance in these algorithms is how
did we perform compared to the best
fixed decision in hindsight and this is
also what is known as the regret of the
online learning algorithm so let's look
at an example for each of these problems
we can model their decisions using some
combinatorial structures so for instance
I could think about pages and assign a
ranking to them or I could think about
objects and assign a permutation to
those objects and say that I'm
displaying a permutation of these
objects or in a graph I could think
about st parts or i could think about
spanning trees and these decisions can
now be modeled in the vector form so you
have some vertices of these polytopes
and the online learning framework says
that okay so let the decision-maker
choose a randomized decision which is a
convex hull of these vertices I'm going
to call these vectors as vertices these
are the pure decisions so I'm allowed to
randomize over them that gives me this
convex space that's the polytope then a
linear loss function is revealed so for
instance let's say I'm looking at
permutations and I say okay I'm going to
play 2 3 1 4 that means that I'm
displaying let's say page 1 I trying to
page 2 I trying 3 3 at 1 & 4 8 4 and
given this display I observe what are
the click-through rates of users so
that's like a linear loss function that
I've
discover that has been revealed to me
and then the algorithm suffers a loss
which is a linear combination of a dot
product of these two vectors and this
simply panel Isis if a highly desired
page is placed at a later rank I'll get
more loss right so yes probability
distribution over there
yes it's linear in the probability
distribution over the vertices and in
fact yes so the linearity plays a key
role in going from the losses on the
vertices to the losses on the
probability distributions otherwise you
could not just they have to be some
assuming they're linear losses yes so if
it's linear in the in the vertices then
it is also linear in the marginals so
it's also linear over the convex
combination of those all right and one
of the algorithms that's in a very broad
class of first order optimization
methods is that of one line when I
descend this is based on the seminal
book of nemirovsky newton in 1983
although the online pathways of an
attribute is encouraged and it attains
optimal regret in many cases but it is
computationally slow and the key reason
for this is for all of these first-order
projection based methods the bottleneck
arises in if you have a point in your
decision set they will typically can do
an unconstrained gradient step that
takes you out of your decision set out
of your feasible set and then you have
to project this point back and obtain
the next iterate or the next probability
distribution that you're going to play
in in this learning setup or in a convex
minimization setup and these projections
are often are obtained by minimizing a
convex function potential in each step
of the method so this forms a
computational bottleneck so this is
going to be the set up the outline of
the talk I'm next going to describe the
problem set up of projections and then
explain our novel algorithm inc fix to
compute these projections on a very
interesting class of combinatorial
polytopes
and then we'll move on to line searches
and learning over heuristics and
algorithms okay so let's talk about
which decision sets am I going to
compute these projections on and the
short answer to that is what are known
as submodular based polytopes if you
have not heard of sub modularity you can
think about you know the problem of
learning rankings or projections and
think about learning over the convex
hull so which is the B of F that's the
base polytope
it's a convex hull of permutations of
numbers from 1 to N and note that this
has an exponential number of vertices in
fact the representation of these
polytopes also uses an exponential
number of constraints so let's quickly
parse what this is this is saying that
the amount of weight that I'm allowed to
raise any subset of elements to that is
X of V summed over in s that is
constrained by a function value on that
subset this function value of FS has
very nice properties that capture
diminishing returns so if you have a set
of elements and you add an element of it
the gain you will get is more if you add
to a smaller subset down to a bigger
subset containing not containing that
element ok and a different choice of the
submodular function f gives you a
different commodore l structure so if
you fix F to be the simple expression
that's only based on the size of the
subset then you get permutations if you
fix it to something else that is based
on the rank of a set of edges the
graphic metroid' rank of a set of edges
then you get spanning trees and you can
essentially play with a lot of variety
of the sub-module function and ok so now
let's look at what are the convex
functions we are minimizing so we are
going to minimize what are known as
Bragman divergences and to understand
what this expression is let's look at a
convex function Omega so this is called
the distance generating function or the
mirror map in all of these first-order
projection based methods and what this
is saying is what's the gap between
Omega of X which is a convex function -
the first order Taylor approximation
why but so this is the gap of Omega X -
what's the lower bound at X based on the
first order Taylor approximation at Y
and plugging in different values of the
Omega function we get different distance
like measures which are square Euclidean
distance scale divergence and this is
what is known as the idler site or
distance which is used to measure the
similarity between audio speech
processing signals and all of these
functions are separable and so this is
what is going to be the setting or the
of convex functions that we consider
we're going to minimize strictly convex
and separable functions over some
modular base polytopes and at this point
one might ask ok why do we care about
all of these different Omega functions
different different generating functions
and so the short answer to that is they
get different convergence and retread
pounds under different law settings
different polytopes and you can just
plug in the Omega function based on the
geometry of the polytope and that give
you a different rate of convergence in
these methods okay so to summarize
they're going to minimize strictly
convex separable functions over sub
model-based polytopes like the squared
Euclidean distance over the convex hull
of permutations
all right so now I'm going to give you
an algorithm by picture so here I have a
point y that is one point four four one
that I want to project onto this base
polytope that's the shaded face and the
way the algorithm works is that I'm go
to view I'm going to start with an
initial point which is which has some
nice properties and starting with that
initial point so that's going to be zero
for me I'm going to look at the partial
derivatives of each of the coordinates
remember that a function was separable
so the partial derivatives only depend
on the value of that coordinate and in
this case the partial derivatives of X E
- ye are just zero - whatever the
y-coordinate is this is why I get Ito at
minus 4
even at minus 1 point 4 and III at minus
1 ok and then I look at the elements
which have the lowest partial derivative
and I increase that uniformly until the
set of elements that have the lowest
partial derivative changes so you see as
I increased Ito - even I had some
movement in the polytope and at this
point the set of minimal partial
derivatives have changed to e1 and e2 at
that point my direction changes because
now the algorithm says ok move these two
uniformly and so I move even an Ito
uniformly that's a new direction in the
pollito until I cannot do that anymore
so if I hit a tight constraint I fixed
the elements that I cannot increase
anymore so it's a tight constraint that
I've hit here at that point I fix Ito
because if I increase in the Ito
direction I'm constrained by this face
so I cannot do that any more and I
continue increasing with the remaining
elements so even an e3 are the minimum
partial derivative elements now and I
increase those uniformly until I hit the
base polytope and that's the algorithm
it gives an exact rejection as long as
you can compute a univariate not a
equation in like exactly so for the
Euclidian case that's just subtracting
two numbers and that involves like just
taking the
inverse of the partial derivatives and
so as long as you can do that it
computes an exact projection or the
exact minimizer of the convex function
say myst what's happening between the
two levels so is it a different
constraint in the base positive that's
becoming tight yes yes so at this point
when I fixed Ito then this face had
become tight that was one of the
constraints and everything else was not
tight at that time and when I increased
even and III then this constraint became
tight that's the sum of all the elements
yes so that's a very good question I'm
going to come to that how do you do this
efficiently always in the interior of
the samoilov polytope so the base
polytope is actually just a face of the
Samana politoed that's just saying that
the total sum of the value of the
elements is equal to the function value
on the entire set I'm always on yeah I'm
always on the relaxed pollito
good okay so this there's some details
on to how to do this movement inside the
polytope that I have brushed another
drug that was exactly your question and
I'm going to get to this in when we
discuss how to do line searches and line
searches means that the second question
that I alluded to that given a point in
the polytope how far can you move along
a direction while staying feasible and
we're going to look at how how do we do
that next
and using some more properties of
structural properties of the minimizer's
of parametric submodular function
submodular functions we can show that
this entire thing can be amortized in
order n sub modular function
minimizations and this result is
independent of the structure of the sir
modular function so as long as only you
have only black box access you don't
need to compute this minimizer exactly
so there are some if the algorithms that
you're using are pseudo polynomial ibiki
polynomial and that can increase the
running time and in special cases though
it's very interesting that infix can be
speeded up to obtain much faster running
times and a special case in that sense
is that of cardinality based functions
so as we saw earlier the permutations
function is cardinality based it only
depends on the size of the subsets that
you're selecting and for this function
I'm going to project some points at
random on the base polytope and I'm
going to plot the gap from optimality on
this plot which says how fast ink fixes
are decreasing in the optimality gap
versus Frank wolf and the vanilla Frank
voles method is something which is very
amenable to convex minimization over
submodular polytopes
because it only asks for a linear
optimization solution which can be
computed using Edmunds Creedy algorithm
so we are going to compare infix to
Frank wolf and here you're going to see
a gradient view so you see how the
gradients are increasing greedily as I
explained in the algorithm and here
you're going to see how the gap from
optimality from for inc fixed
decreasing quite fast and Frank fulfills
still sort of trying to get approximate
solutions and it's getting better all
the time now this happens for cases
where just it happens for cardinality
based functions for certain
distributions but it's interesting that
in fix since it's an exact method it can
do much better than Frank wolf okay so
with this let me move on to the second
part which is line searches and what do
line searches do so as I said earlier
here we are going to look at the
extended poly Metroid so initially my
submodular function the polytope is
constrained with non-negative variables
but now I can also take negative values
and the question I want to ask is
suppose I am in inside these exponential
number of hyper planes I'm inside this a
modular pollito how far can I move while
staying feasible and it's a sub problem
in infix but in flex only uses positive
directions which was well understood
using the method that I'm going to
explain next and also invariance of
Frank wolf in the carathéodory's theorem
to decompose a point into its vertices
as a convex combination and has also
been used for other problems like
densest sub graphs and minimum ratio
problems and the best known method for
this which was strongly polynomial used
n to the eighth sub monitor function
minimizations so this was a
prohibitively large running time
nevertheless it was a polynomial method
and this was given by Nagano in 2011 and
just to remind us the constraints of the
sub monitor polytope looks something
like this so the sum of the values on
any sub set is bounded by the function
value and as I move a point so as I move
along the direction let's say lambda D
from zero then I just want to figure out
what the solution of this equation is
which is as I move in that direction D
of s what's the maximum lambda such that
this is still positive right this is
when lambda D will satisfy this a
modular constraints okay so what I can
do as a thought experiment for every
set a subset of the ground elements I
can plot a line that just depends on the
parameter lambda as I increase that line
at some point I get negative values and
I continue plotting those for all of the
subsets and I obtain what I'm interested
in is this lower envelope of all of
these linear functions right and I want
to find this parameter this maximum
lambda star value at which my envelope
is still positive right it doesn't go
below zero and it's very natural to look
at the discrete Newton method for a
parametric line search what does that do
it just samples at a lambda but I
definitely know I am violating at least
one constraint that's easy to break you
just fix an element and violate the
constraint for that and then I do a
submerge a function minimization to find
out what this set is that gives me the
lower the value of the lower envelope at
that point I can look at I can set that
set to zero and get another value of
lambda and continue this process until I
converge to this lambda star and it was
an open question what the number of
iterations of this method it I for
general directions for positive
directions it's easy to show that it can
only be a linear number of iterations
and a linear number of breakpoints
actually in the lower envelope and we
show a quadratic bound in the number of
Newton's iterations that's getting an
order n to the six improvement in the
running time from the best strongly
polynomial known algorithm so with this
let me move on to the next part which is
so let me skip over this this is sort of
giving some intuition on the proof we
can come back to this if there's time at
the end and let's move on to what works
best when so what are we doing here
initially we started thinking about
online learning problems as problems
where I want to learn over a set of
rankings I want to get some feedback I
want to show a better ranking to my
users in the next iteration but now we
are going to think about you know like a
giant sitting with
has a large set of ensemble of
algorithms and given any new data
instance I'm just trying to figure out
which algorithm to use on that data
instance and if I can do that better so
what's happening here is that okay you
encounter some problem in practice you
find out what is known about that
problem and then sort of the best known
heuristic for that setting right like
often we have thread achill results
let's say okay if you have lower
sparsity or lower policy team in sofia
stock then you do something like that or
we saw in Puritan index talked earlier
today that if you have dense clusters
and you do this if you have sparse
clusters and you do if you don't have
clusters then you do something else
right so we want to understand what is
the what are the properties of our
instances that can help us select which
algorithm to work best on and really we
are trying to move from learning
decisions to learning the performance of
algorithms and we started looking so
this is joint work with in Dunning and
John silver holes and we started looking
at what happened was that we joined as
grad students in the operations Research
Center and used to think about okay you
know what if we had an integer
programming solver that could we could
run a lot of things on that just
generated conjectures for us and we
could just sit and prove those
conjectures right so this is this is
what we're thinking when we are when
join was faced with running maxcut on
very dense graphs because he was trying
to do named disambiguation in some
google scholar references so we started
looking at max cut and we were like okay
it's what is max cut max cup max cut is
a very famous np-hard problem which says
that given an edge weighted graph I want
to partition nodes into two subsets such
as the weight of the edges between them
is maximized and it also has an
equivalence with the quadratic
unconstrained binary optimization
problem which just says that I want to
maximize X transpose QX for a given
matrix X that's the quadratic on
constraint binary optimization and a lot
of applications a lot of research one of
the applications also that I found quite
interesting was trying to detect dense
activity graphs
event networks so let's say you have
some visa card get some transaction data
and you're trying to understand if
there's a card which has multiple
declined transactions from various
vendors you want to quickly detect that
card and mark that as a fraud that fraud
is happening on that so they're also one
could use Mac's card and a lot of
heuristics that are used in practice and
really for these heuristics
computational experiments are the key to
understanding what would work best when
and but it's hard to find which
heuristic works best because of the
standard testbed at the time so the
standard testbed had very few graphs in
max the max card instances had very low
density there were some 128 graphs 105
crafts in that and the Cubo matrices had
very few that were low density and was
really hard to find which maxcut
heuristic would actually work best for
dense graphs that was what we started
with and further okay so this was yeah
this was the problem that we faced and
further when we looked at a large number
of papers so this is 95 papers which
were highly cited in max Carr heuristics
literature we realized that no only 10%
of the papers used same runtime limits
or the same hardware so it's very
difficult to compare heuristics if they
don't have if they are running on two
different hardware or they're running
for different runtime limits right then
you have no idea of which would work
scat instances I thought you were trying
this in vain scrubs
right so so we couldn't find which max
kashira stick would work in this area
right the the standard test bed only had
very low density graphs and the standard
test bed for cube only had had these
data instances so it didn't have any
sparse density notes sparse densely
matrices and write further previous
heuristic so the number of previous
heuristics that compared against ten
papers is less than five mostly they
compare against one people and so that's
that sort of door histogram right okay
and so we said okay you know what we're
going to do we're going to expand the
standard test path we are going to look
at what are the popular in max kashira
states we're going to run everything on
the cloud cloud so this is just a table
of ten hints from the paper that I put
in here and then we are going to go to
more interesting questions that we can
ask with all of this data that we've
collected okay so let's look at the in
expanded instance library so here we
thought of okay how do we get a large
variety of graphs that make this an
interesting problem and we collected
heterogeneous instances from there are
some other known libraries for 9/4
np-hard problems like tsp lip Stein lip
die max is a set of challenges they have
a set of challenges they have various
u.s. road networks for different states
and cities we took all of them in we
used a lot of network science generators
like it or any humans what Strogatz
barbar see Albert we used a bunch of
those these then cross producted that
with a bunch of weights from different
probability distributions we constructed
like almost more than 3000 like 3000 to
3300 graphs and that's the coverage of
the space for the new instances so this
is the max cut instances in the original
graph this is these are the cue board
flipped and then the gray dots are the
ones that we expanded our library toe
and this is just a displayed on
different
access okay and then we said okay so
these are sort of the properties that we
buried to get all of these instances
there are some global metrics like first
and second eigenvalues of the laplacian
chromatic number and then there are a
large number of local metrics that look
at the clustering coefficient of the
vertices the average neighborhood degree
the the code of the graph the a sort of
80 which was our excuse me correlation
between the degrees of two neighboring
vertices and so on and our criterion was
that we only want features of graphs
that are fast to compute and I'm going
to get to that later in the talk why is
that important and then we said okay you
know it looks nice it passes the eyeball
test that we've covered a lot of the
space but can we actually formally
define a coverage metric that says that
okay if I look at a particular feature
of the graph and I assign a small 0.25
epsilon interval around it and I just
plot the number of graphs that I have
from 0 to 1 then I get something like
this so these are all our 58 metrics and
this is what the standard test bed
covered and this is what we covered in
the end so standard test bed was not too
bad it still had a wide coverage of a
lot of the metrics but then we could get
almost complete coverage for all of
these metrics that we considered ok all
right
the next step was the large-scale
evaluation on Amazon ec2 cloud and
implementation of heuristics so we redid
what would what was expected right we we
did a thorough literature review we got
some 810 papers we selected 95 with new
heuristics we implemented 37 of those
heuristics so that we didn't have to
import external solvers we didn't have
to solve SDPs from these 19 highly cited
papers and and then we sort of
standardized the codebase and we said ok
you know they should use similar data
structures they should use shared swap
algorithms and so on and we also didn't
want to do any parameter tuning so we
sort of took the parameters that were
published
various papers or we try to get around
that we enveloped algorithms into random
restarts so that their competitor with
the deterministic ones and and then we
done everything on easy to we selected
the runtime heuristic the runtime limit
up front so we said okay for a given
graph what's the time taken to generate
15,000 random solutions and what's the
time taken to do one swap so the max cut
heuristic uses the swap metric right so
you take a cut and you just move one
here one vertex and you figure out which
is the best what vertex to move to the
compliment of the cut and we just
computed what's so we standardized the
run times
with respect to these this process and
any new heuristic now takes around 20
CPU days and select $32 to test a new
heuristic in this setup all of this code
is available on github library so it's
all open source and you can all free
feel free to play with it and okay so so
we did all of this implementation and we
ran all of this on the cloud and now we
could actually ask some interesting
questions we realized that actually no
heuristic dominated on all the instances
which was very interesting in the
standard testbed it seemed like some in
some heuristics were not doing too well
for instance there's GLS so this is
genetic algorithm with local search
heuristic of morals and Fry's has been
in 99
it was strictly best on no instance in
the standard test bed but was strictly
based on six point nine seven percent
instances in the expanded aspect so that
just shows that you know you cannot
write off any heuristic without
extensively testing it and no heuristic
matched the best performance on more
than twenty two point nine percent of
the test bed so this was also an
interesting point that I could not just
select one heuristic and say that you
know that's the best heuristic for max
cut instances I actually need to look at
in different areas of the instance space
which is working the best and then sort
of make
big algorithmic portfolio fit those and
we'll get to that okay and this is sort
of the the ranking which is interesting
this is the average rank so these ranks
are from one to thirty seven right
averaged over all the interesting
instances in our data set the non
interesting instances are the ones that
are just solved to optimality by each
heuristic so we just threw them out and
and we sort of we looked at deviation
from the best solution what are the
instances with the top performance and
so on by the way the the top heuristic
here is bureau 2002 that's based on rank
two approximation of the Gomez
Williamson algorithm so that's quite
interesting that it performed that way
and okay so the question is can we
predict which heuristic would work best
on an unseen data instance and when we
ask this question then we faced a lot of
skepticism that you know these are
np-hard problems you and these are
heuristics you can't really prove
anything about them so the fact that
you're trying to learn how how well they
perform with respect to properties of
instances that seems like it will it
will not give you any promising results
and we looked further into into this
literature and rice in 1976 already said
that you know the algorithmic selection
problem which is this problem we are
talking about is to really learn the
mapping from instance features to the
best algorithm to run on an instance
right for every instance if I could just
learn one number which said how hard is
this instance for the heuristic then I
could predict what the performance of
that heuristic would be and so it's
really key to get to those set of
features that are representative of the
hardness of the instance and when we
selected these heuristics these features
sorry and we we asked that you know how
well do we cover these feature values
then a lot of these features have also
come from various studies like phase
transition studies that say that okay
you know if the density
the graph is less than so-and-so and
then any random here any random solution
is going to be so much approximate to
the optimal one if the density is more
than that any random solution is going
to be something which is not that good
right so people have done a lot of phase
transition studies or landscape analysis
to understand what IDs so their focus
these studies focus on one property one
feature and ask something about the
hardness of yes okay how good with a
random solution be or how good can a
greedy algorithm be for for these kind
of instances and so these properties are
sort of taking a lot from from these
studies as well and here's what we found
so we we wanted to have some
interpretable heuristic performance
models that told us that okay you know
if the properties of the graph are in
these buckets then the heuristic is
going to perform well or not and for all
of the 37 heuristics we trained cut
models to give us a diagram like that so
the depth was restricted to I think
three or four variables and what this is
saying is okay if there is this mis
property which is less than 0.3 for to 2
then it's basically giving me the cuts
in the space that tell me whether a
heuristic will perform this heuristic
performs good or not and what it's
predicting is it's it's ranked out of
the 1 to 37 heuristics and here what you
see is the red dots are where it
achieved close to thirty seventh ranked
blue dots are where it achieved close to
one rank and there's a clear sort of an
area where this heuristic actually does
perform pretty well compared to all of
the rest
37 heuristics now this Mis is an
interesting feature that we added into
our set of features it just computes
what's the approximate maximum
independent set and it seems like
somehow that has a very high predictive
property for these interpreter for
predicting what is the heuristic
performance it was for us it was like
okay can we ask the
be hard problem what it thinks about
this instance and that sort of what
we're trying to capture with the maximum
independent set which is like a just a
greedy answer to that okay
and so these cart models now one can ask
a lot of conjectures one can ask if you
know why is the case that if the
independent set a greedy independent set
in the graph is more than 0.3 for to do
then this heuristic actually performs
pretty well it gets close to the best
solution the numbers that you see in the
notes or the rank that it's predicted by
the cart model and now if two heuristics
have the same the same variables that
the cart model split on then you can
also look at okay so it seems that this
heuristic for the same instances when
does one heuristic performance so it can
be used to compare performance in
different regimes and further what we
did was we bucketed these heuristics in
two styles of the algorithms so let's
say we took one which was just
evolutionary algorithms so all of
evolutionary algorithms went into that
bucket all of taboo search algorithms
went into this bucket and we asked okay
if I do this ensemble of heuristics have
the best performance and so this is
basically saying that Tabo search does
not perform well for low-density graphs
but it performs very well for
high-density and here it's more complex
again it's it asks it begs a question
like you know why is this the case and
how can we explain this behavior that
you observe in this analysis all right
and the last part was that okay now we
have all of this data we have 37
heuristics we have the way these
heuristics have performed the way the
solution has progressed for like let's
say I think close to 3,000 graphs and
then can we actually just look at the
features of these instances and select a
heuristic that will perform
supposedly the best given those features
and we trained a random four ass model
for each heuristic that split up spit
out a probability that this heuristic is
going to perform the best on this
instance and then we selected the
heuristic which has the highest
predictor probability and of course like
so we had a runtime budget for each of
the instances we allocated a part of it
to compute the features select a
heuristic and ran that heuristic for the
remaining time and this increased the
probability of obtaining the best
solution from 15 percent to 37 the 15
percent is if you selected a single best
heuristic this was the bureau in 2002
but by doing this switching of
heuristics and selection using the
random forest we could increase that to
37% and average deviation from the best
solution so this is not the exact
destination because we don't know what
the best solution is we didn't solve the
exact problems but this is the best
solution that was obtained by any of the
heuristics that we had so that decreased
2.0 9% and then we said okay what if we
select a set of heuristics and we let
them run in parallel for the allocated
amount of time and at that point we
realized that 48 percent of the times we
can actually achieve the best solution
okay so with that I think I'm done thank
you and I'm happy to take any questions
[Applause]
this work it seemed to suggest you could
turn it around into a way of generating
heart of the instances yes so there's a
lot of studies where people try to
generate hard instances by using
evolutionary algorithms and evolving an
instance and then seeing if you know
swapping some pairs have highly likely a
high likelihood of generating higher
instances or not what we did was we
didn't want to get into all of that but
we said okay we are going to run an
instance on we are going to run all the
heuristics on an instance and you're
going to see if all of the heuristics
achieve the same answer then it's
probably easy and then we threw away all
of those so we did a trimming but it's
hard to say whether it was hard for
every heuristic or whether it was simple
for every heuristic but basically
because there was no difference in the
performance we just threw them out
could you not this puzzle for mascot but
I know further exits always and stuff
they try to do this kind of you know
they do you look over all possible
combinations of a subset of variables
that breaks down the problem into
independence of parts that maybe each of
your heuristics can solve those in it
okay so we didn't do any of that
there also studies that switch
heuristics so at some point in the run
time they're going to stop and they're
going to switch your heuristic if you
don't get any improvement we also didn't
do that
we just did like select one here to
stick and run it for the entire time
feature space and see the physics for
Hyper heuristic drop down a lot you see
30 out of 60 yes so I think what you're
asking me is like what was the
importance of these different features
right
this is the table we are looking for
this is the mean decrease in the Gini
coefficients in the random forest models
if you added a feature so some of these
features were actually they were they
were not useful at all so you could just
drop them but some of the features so
there are some top 10 features here up
to here I think yeah which are which are
pretty significant in the prediction
the question all right let's think funny